Hi, I'm Dr. Joe Hall Patton, or Cypher
on this channel, and I'd like to talk
about how there are various fields in
history. And there's many ways of
dividing up the fields of history, for
instance, just by topic. My specific
topic of research is American violence,
which is referring to violence on a
social level, such as riots,
filibusters, or vigilantism, rather than
martial violence, like official military
action, or interpersonal violence, as in
normal crimes. Or you can go by era, for
my era is the frontier period from 1848
to 1919. And there's a whole argument
over when the modern era, medieval era,
and previous eras began. So, I would be
considered a modernist because I study
the period after the Renaissance, as in
the modern period. Then you can divide
fields by geography, for instance, I
study the US Southwest. So, if you
combine all those specific fields
together, I study American violence in
the frontier Southwest. So, you can
divide up the history profession by
those fields, or you can also divide it
by audience, what the intended audience
would be. For instance, what I'm doing
here could be considered public history.
So, you have pop, public, and scholarly
history. I have an entire diatribe on
that alone. Scholarly history is meant
for other scholars, as in very academic
history, or pop history, which is
intended solely for a popular audience.
Public history is kind of in between.
Another division would be by
historiographic position. So, like
orthodox, revisionist, and
post-revisionist. I also have an entire
episode on that, as well. The orthodoxy
is the first to write and kind of create
a triumphalist narrative, revisionists
critique that, and post-revisionists
find a new way from those two previous
positions. And technically, all history
is revisionist. You can't really be
writing anything new if you're not
revising the old. But the term
revisionist here is more referring to
somebody who is revising the orthodoxy,
the triumphalist narrative. But if you
go beyond that binary of good versus
evil and everything, then you get to
post-revisionist. I, like most
historians today, fit the
post-revisionist category. It's more of
a placeholder term for when we decide on
what to call the last couple decades of
historiography. Then you can also divide
the fields by style, as in are they
writing in a more narrative form, or a
more analytical form. These are two
different styles of writing history. But
there is an even deeper division, and
it's not what you think. It is divided
by methodology.
>> [music]
>> Now, historians have a method overall,
and that is something that we all must
keep in order to be historians and write
history. You can't have a profession
without professional standards. So, in
order to write history, you first have
to read what is already out there, the
secondary sources. Then you get to
primary source research, where you read
wide and deep of the primary sources you
can get a hold of. And through that
process, you formulate a thesis and
something to argue. All history has an
argument to it. And finally, you can get
to writing. And there's some core pieces
of how you write history, for instance,
how you do bibliographic entries, or
citation standards. In the United
States, we use the Chicago Manual of
Style, for instance. It uses footnotes,
because only inferior styles use
parenthetical citations. And of course,
there should be standard ways of writing
that include an introduction, and that
introduction needs to have some sort of
historiography that positions your work
in the greater corpus of other
historians writing on that topic. And
yeah, all historians do this. There is a
unifying methodology across the entire
profession.
If you aren't doing those specific
things, you aren't a historian. But
still, that's the larger methodology.
Then the fields kind of break apart by
methodology, depending on the topic that
you're trying to draw out. And these
core fields are kind of the main
division of how historians think about
themselves. As far as I can tell,
there's only seven, so let's go through
each of them. The methodological fields
of history are cultural, political,
social, economic, biographical,
military, and intellectual history. I'm
firmly in the cultural history field,
and we'll get into why that is. But
first, the oldest fields in the
profession are probably military,
political, and biographical history.
It's kind of obvious, for instance,
political means what the elites decide
how power should be arranged. That's
political history, so you are trying to
study elites and what decisions they
make in terms of arranging power.
Military history is about how war is
fought and organized, and biography is
the story of specific people. Each of
these fields dictate sourcing, subject,
and purpose. So, for politics, you're
obviously using like legislative
records, and the memoirs of the various
politicians, and the minutes of various
meetings and stuff like that. All of
which you are trying to figure out how
power is arranged. Biography is kind of
similar, but you're focusing on one
individual and all the documents that
surround that person. In military
history, obviously, you use the memoirs
of the soldiers, but also the records
that are generated by all the various
orders and movements of the military.
So, each require a very specific
research method, but their ultimate
purpose is to either appreciate or
understand prestige and dominance.
Ancient historians focused on particular
leaders and tried to tell good stories.
Well into the modern era, as historians
became professionalized in the 19th
century, that triumphalist narrative
continued to play a massive role in
these particular fields. And of course,
with military history, commanders want
to learn from the past in order to not
make the mistakes of previous
commanders. These were the main fields
when history became a profession, hence
why they're often considered almost
obsolete, at least if unmodified,
and can be quite detrimental if
unmodified, because the entire
profession came about to basically
create nationalism. That's why more
orthodox historians tend to be in these
fields because they want to promote
nationalism. And that's caused a lot of
harm to the world. In fact, it's kind of
the foundational myth to the entire
history profession. We're still trying
to get past it. Yet, more orthodox
political, military, and biographical
history are still kind of the most
popular forms of history today. So, even
while the profession is trying to get
away from it with new fields of
methodology,
the public keeps on trying to pull us
back. The next two were kind of
consequences of the beginning three
methodologies, which are intellectual
and economic histories. As you starts
trying to study elites, you want to know
how they are either gaining their
wealth, or gaining their perspective.
So, economic history is inherently
materialist. And by the way, that term
long predates Marx, and Marxists do not
have a monopoly on that term. Ha,
monopolistic Marxists.
>> [laughter]
>> All economic historians are
materialists, and therefore they are
focusing on the material reality of
human interaction, rather than the
ideology behind it. That tends to be a
lot more data-driven and reliant on
economic theory. Whereas, intellectual
history is trying to understand how
those theories come about. They're
either trying to figure out where ideas
come from, or how they transformed over
time. So, intellectual history just kind
of started off as like the history of
philosophy, but as that evolved, it
started turning into things like
commodity history, which is an odd
combination of intellectual and economic
history, where it's the history of the
idea of a commodity through economic
history. And commodity histories are
actually some of the most fun books to
read if you're looking for stuff. By the
end of World War II, there was a new
social history coming about. This
methodology focuses on history from the
bottom up. So, it's more about ordinary
life, how regular people live. But what
made it particularly new in the 1950s
was the advent of structuralism as a
theory. The idea that there is an
inherent structure to how societies
function. These sociological theories
undergird the entirety of the new social
history, giving an explanation of how
ordinary life worked throughout society,
and giving a new impetus to find sources
that explain that ordinary life. But by
the 1960s, there was a new method that
was coming up as part of what was known
as either the linguistic or cultural
turn. Those are two separate things, but
they kind of run together. As scholars
started looking at social history, they
also started realizing that there is an
entire layer of meaning that we add to
ordinary life and see the world through
that culture. So, there is something
symbolized by change. By looking at
change over time, i.e., history,
cultural historians are looking for how
that is symbolized. And that's why I am
a cultural historian. I study American
violence to see what change is being
signified by that violence. This means
that cultural historians tend to do a
lot of ethnography, as in the study of a
culture and description of it, and
textual analysis. So, even the title of
my dissertation kind of shows the
symbolic meaning because it is called
great excitement. Throughout the 19th
century and early 20th century, it was
very common to use the term great
excitement to refer to some sort of
societal-level violence, that society is
in a state of excitement. This could be
something as simple as a lynching to as
big as a massive feud resulting in
multiple massacres. But the violence in
and of itself is hard to read unless you
are looking at it as a symbol of change.
This is what I call violence as symbol
analysis. It is core to what I do as a
historian. So, you can see how you can
fit pretty much any history into these
seven methodological fields. As a
reminder, they are political, military,
biography, economic, intellectual,
social, and cultural history. But
there's a lot of stuff that I wouldn't
really know how where to put it in these
things or might overlap with those seven
categories. Like where does labor,
maritime, national, transnational,
gender, memory, environmental, art, and
technological history fit into those
seven categories? It can be one, two, or
all of them, depending on how one
approaches that subject. So, these
different methods inevitably bleed into
each other, and you can't exactly
separate them fully. It's often
necessary for me to dip into political
and military history in order to get at
the symbolic meaning of violence. So,
while each of these seven fields
describe a very specific methodology,
those methodologies overlap and can't be
fully differentiated. So, this might all
seem overly broad and not necessarily
something that would ever affect you.
But in reality, the methodological lens
that you put on of these seven different
methods
affects how you think about the world.
There is always perspective to how
history is told. There is no such thing
as a fully objective history. That is
impossible. It always fits in one of
these fields, if not multiple. And
perspective isn't just experiential. It
isn't just driven by your own
experience, but it is driven by your
choice in the way that you interpret the
world. And we all choose that. Whether
consciously or unconsciously, we all
have that frame to think about the
world.
>> [music]
>> And that includes history, because
history is the story of us. We tell that
story. So, circling all the way back
around, what kind of historian am I? I
study American violence in the Southwest
during the frontier period. That means I
am a cultural historian because I'm
looking for the symbolic meaning of that
violence. Tell me in the comments below
what frame of reference do you think you
have? What methodology are you taking on
to interpret the world?
>> [music]
[music]